Is a really quite interesting experiments that we
did some time ago happened quite by chance.
So what happened was that Neil, uh,
tireless technician had to empty some cylinders of
noble gases.
So Particularly Xenon
Krypton, uh, neon, you may think that this is great extravagance,
but when you buy guests in the way that we do,
you pay a rental on the cylinders.
Hello, I'm now don't get me helium in my voice.
When the cylinders nearly empty,
you're paying much more for renting it than the value of the gas inside.
So eventually you just have to get rid of the last bit of gas if you don't have
an urgent experiment.
So I persuaded Neil to fill some balloons
with neon, Krypton and Xenon,
and to make them all the same size.
And because scientists like to do a control experiment,
he also blew one up with nitrogen.
This all happened in a great hurry. Neil had to empty the cylinders quickly,
Brady wasn't in knotting. Um,
so we filmed it ourselves, not me,
but one of my colleagues, but you will see,
I didn't even have time to put on a tie. When I appear on the film,
what I wanted to do was to demonstrate two different things.
The first thing I wanted to show the difference in density of the
gas is the heavier gas.
Like Krypton should fall much faster, the neon,
which should almost float. And when same, uh,
Neal released all four blue balloons at the same time,
you can see the Xenon does fall quite a lot faster.
So if you had like, you know, a feather and a hammer and these sort of things,
that mass is irrelevant and things should fall at the same time.
Of course, this is true in a vacuum,
but if you have a balloon,
which is very large compared to its mass air
resistance is important.
So then the weight does become significant.
And if you watch, you can see the neon
falls much more slowly than the Xenon and Krypton.
Of course, if you had helium, it would've go on the other way.
Yeah, of course. Helium should have gone up. In fact,
neon is light to the narrow and also should have gone up,
but you've got to remember that the balloon also has a weight,
so the neon was more or less neutral.
And so it went down just rather slowly.
Now there was another reason they wanted the balloons filled.
And this is because I really wanted to have a balloon of Xenon
in my office.
I could show to visitors.
And my idea was that the gas in the balloon leaks
out also,
I thought by a process called diffusion and light
molecules,
like neon diffuse much faster than heavy
atoms like CNO.
The reason is that light molecules travel faster.
So the Neo on the banging away at the sides of the balloon all the time,
the Xenon, while traveling slower,
doesn't hit the site so frequently. So it shouldn't go through so fast.
So I expected that the neon balloon would deflate quite quickly,
but the Xenon balloon would stay for a long time and I could show it to
visit us and say, wow, look a balloon of Xenon.
So after the dropping experiment,
the balloons were taken to my office and you can see from the photo,
they were more or less the same size.
The next day I was horrified.
The Xenon balloon had got small. So I ran down and told Neil,
he hadn't filled it up properly and persuade to attempt to fill another one.
I thought he hadn't tied the knot properly at the end of the balloon,
but the next day the same thing had happened.
The Xenon balloon had got small and I was really puzzled.
But then I discovered that my theory was wrong.
In fact, there'd been a paper published exactly a hundred years ago,
which showed the rate at which gases diffuse
through the fabric of rubber balloons.
And they didn't use Xenon because it's so expensive,
but they use carbon dioxide,
which has very similar properties to Xenon.
And it turns out that carbon dioxide diffuses
out of a balloon much faster than the hydrogen,
because it dissolves in the rubber and the same must be true for Xenon as
well.
I suddenly learnt something that reason that gases come out of
balloons is not just a fusion,
but it's the rate at which they dissolve in the rubber. How does Xenon.
Dissolve in rubber what's going on.
There? Well, the rubber is, if you like,
like a very viscous liquid,
it's not really a crystalline solid.
And so material can dissolve in the rubber. What do you mean by dissolve?
Well, it is just the same as dissolving in a liquid,
the atoms of Xenon or molecules,
because the molecule has only one atom goes between the chains of
the rubber molecules,
just in the same way as it would dissolve in the liquid.
So the Xenon dissolves in the rubber, which is quite thin.
And then it goes through the rubber and comes out the other side,
rather zip would do through three thin film of liquid.
I would have big Xenon atom have an easier time desolving than
say a neon atom, which is much smaller.
I think it's because the scene on that term interacts more strongly with
the rubber, uh,
than the neon and therefore energetically.
It is favorable for the Xenon to go into the rubber
compared to the neon.
So I think that this experiment demonstrates
two things. That's three.
The first thing it demonstrates the difference between a demonstration
where you're showing something that you know is going to happen.
We knew that Xenon was heavier than neon,
so we knew it would fall faster. The other part,
the size of the balloon turned out to be an experiment.
An experiment is where you do something.
When beforehand you have a hypothesis.
If you'd like a theory,
I had the hypothesis that neon would come out faster than
Xenon.
We did the experiment and showed that it was wrong.
Xenon came out fast to the neon.
So it was almost, you intended to do a demonstration that turned into an X.
Precisely. And then it demonstrated the third thing,
which is chemists or scientists like me.
Can't possibly know everything, even though it's a hundred years ago,
since the paper on gases in balloons had been published,
I knew nothing about it until I actually seen the effect
and then search for papers and found that it was well known.
The important thing is that once never too young or too old to
learn things like very high voltage,
you can excite the electrons in the helium and it emits light.
And then with a small spectroscope,
you can look at it and see the very yellow line that was detected in the sun
spectrum.